i might leap
no longer
is she
my lib yeah unfortunately no longer blue
eyes
big rip dude yeah big rip first time
that's ever happened on the show i'm
pretty sure
yeah i got a conspiracy theory what is
it
they were never real
[Laughter]
jake is a robot programmed by the
producers yeah and liberty was all cgi
[Laughter]
they're never actually on the show
they're actually just two people in
motion capture suits wow the whole time
yeah wow
see that i have a feeling that they have
been like that for a little while
yeah
and the the editing didn't give it away
and like the because
that amount of distress
for liberty is not like you woke up and
it happened over a couple days
that to me is like built up and it's
like oh man this clearly ain't working
yeah so like wanna walk out of a
building because you feel like you're
trapped like the both of them felt that
way yeah
that [ __ ] yeah it must have been going
on for a little while yeah
and
maybe the producers were like you [ __ ]
you
don't do it keep it together you [ __ ]
yeah you might win yeah and they're just
trying to get in here you might you
might [ __ ] win dude
oh you think they do that just give them
a little hint yeah maybe hey man i can't
give you a number but
you got a lot of votes people are liking
you guys
hey man you want to break up that's cool
i'm just saying
looks good for you guys
your call your call totally your call
do you back yourself gotta back yourself
yeah
gotta back yourself [ __ ] douchey
american yeah
not english producers at all yeah yeah
just using their slang yeah hey you
gotta back yourself totally i get it
yeah you don't wanna get up there and
look like a mug i totally get it yeah
it's it's tough and even worse it's
mugging someone off exactly awful awful
you know you don't want your journey in
here to be total rubbish yeah
yeah and plus i mean
she's been your whole love island
journey so you don't want to just throw
that away yeah exactly oh maybe you do
man maybe you do in which case
do you back yourself yeah
just know it's looking pretty [ __ ]
good
just know usually between now and the
finale
it's usually around 100 000 followers
that people get but i'm just gonna say
that i'm gonna leave it at that if you
leave now i mean that doesn't matter to
you that's totally fine yeah that's just
like an extra 100 000 followers yeah
could equate to thousands of dollars a
year but
feel free to take off if you guys want i
mean this place is kind of stuffy
anyways you know
we also booked a yacht for you on friday
but that's
it's neither here nor there
yeah
party little party happening so we're
gonna give you guys two glasses of wine
instead of just one so
but i guess i have to give the yacht to
someone else yes door's open so if you
wanna
it's totally open
so if you wanna just mosey on out feel
free
feel free we will leave after the yacht
okay all right
jake we got a real hot blonde girl
coming in on friday
[Laughter]
super sexy big boobs on this one
blue eyes so
you know but uh would be a shame if you
didn't get to meet her then he pulls the
chip out of the back of his head
i'm
he leaving the chip out of his own head
he just reaches in
he's [ __ ]
you can't keep he's squirting from the
back of his neck on the wall
turn around like this and spray everyone
in the face oh
[ __ ] oh i'm leaving i'm leaving
[Laughter]
reinsert him please i
i'm leaving i love liberty love island
2021 love it just recap them up
jake
i love you
i love you
you have so many talk shows to do once
the show's over after sun
i love after sun
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know what did you think i
feel like it's coming like
i feel like when it happened i just sort
of felt like yeah yeah i saw jake he was
like oh
so we're gonna go our separate ways then
is that what you're saying yeah bam dude
you didn't fight for her at all no
literally at all no he's like where is
this coming from yeah she's like i don't
know i just feel like you don't like me
and he's like damn
well you're right yeah so it's good so
yeah peace yeah so we're we're chilling
then
yeah word holy [ __ ] thank god such a
weight off my back [ __ ] i can stop doing
this accent too jesus christ
oh my gosh dude oh my gosh man
it was hard doing that for eight weeks
straight i mean damn
you guys talk like that every day that
is crazy bro
straight up
you want to do this yacht thing or what
yeah i love yachts dude
yeah no he did that's why i think it had
just been like going and that's why he
just rolled over on it yeah
so we're done cool yeah
wow i mean also that we're still we're
still friends yeah
awesome
that little moment where
he was like
why are you so messy you're giving me
the ick yeah i was like that i was like
oh that sounds like a
six month one year into living with each
other argument yeah like pissed i agree
that was uh you know there was
not a lot of jest there mostly truth
yeah you know and the look i was like i
was joking or whatever and i was like i
don't think you were no
you're giving me the ick babe
i was just joking he makes that sound
yeah
[ __ ] disgusting
it's so funny to scream at someone
you're giving me the ick
it's like it's
it's so shitty
ew what the [ __ ] you're giving me the
ink
clean your [ __ ] dirty shorts off of
the ground gross give me the [ __ ] egg
[ __ ] repulsive
[Laughter]
look at him right in the face
[Laughter]
i felt so bad for her i know such like
an innocent person i know
she's just staring like what the [ __ ]
dude
and the fact that she's like crying
working up the confidence to be like
yeah i'm a little messy it's like jesus
man
jake's just [ __ ] taking shots at like
a caribou just innocent just like
i want someone to love me for me i will
never love you
you oh god you give the ick so bad as
long as you leave your stupid shorts on
the ground i will never love you know
that
[Laughter]
putrid human
deviant little pest
[Laughter]
you disgusting little cockroach
i want everyone listening to who lives
with their significant other to just
scream at them you're giving me the ick
after they do something like super
mundane and just see how that works out
i'm just trying to think of something so
stupid why do you why do you leave the
faucet running when you brush your teeth
or give me the [ __ ] egg give me the
ick gross
[ __ ]
don't kiss me in the
morning give me the before you brush
your teeth it's gross
see that's gross see if that just
doesn't ruin an entire night and spark a
four-hour argument
with your giving me the egg [ __ ]
garlic again are you serious
yeah do that
and then after they get their feelings
hurt
uh
walk out of the room and gaslight them
and go where's this coming from
when they're like can i talk to you like
about what yeah
that thing you said earlier they hurt my
feet where's this coming from where's
this coming from what do you mean we're
fine i was joking i was completely
joking when i said you give me the ick
with your nasty ass breath in the
morning yeah
completely babe are you not like picking
up on are we on like different pages in
terms of humor or
yeah you thought we had the there's no
sense of humor are you not picking up
when i'm putting down like it's a bit
like your breath was ass and that was
the joke
if you really gotta lighten up
jeez
i'm gonna head out take some time to
think yeah
and then you just go to the toxic as
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
take some time to think about that
scoots down two seats
falls asleep
it's seven o'clock
island time
yeah damn